hello and welcome to a Thanksgiving
edition of The Bleacher Report fantasy
football show presented by State Farm my
name is Adam Levitan as always joined by
Mike Leone to talks through fantasy
football here ahead of week 12 Michael
Happy Thanksgiving how's it going it's
going well I know this is you know your
favorite holiday of the year so happy to
be celebrating here with you yes while
my family will be eating
directly from the butt of a turkey I
will be watching football and hoping
that things can go well on today's show
we are going to answer some questions
from the chat we're going to talk about
some players we like as starts this week
we like some player we're going to talk
about some players we like as sits this
week we'll also talk about some bundles
while we wait for some more people to
get in here let's take a couple
questions from chat real quick here
Leone from 4pf jeansy picket or car this
week so we get the offensive coordinator
change in Pittsburgh we also have Derek
Carr coming off of a concussion we're
projecting him in right now to get
cleared I kind of think the Saints
should stick with jamus anyways but I'm
not sure that they will considering how
much money they paid to Derek Carr I
don't know how much the offensive
coordinator stuff matters for me I think
if Carr is cleared it would probably be
him for me from the gut but yeah what do
you think about this one Leon I'm with
you if car is cleared I'm going to go
with him you've got a team total about
four three three to four points higher
for New Orleans and I mean it's absurd
the amount of games we've seen with zero
touchdown passes from Kenny picket you
know relative to an average NFL starter
so you're just really not giving up on
any sort of upside whereas for New
Orleans we've seen some games where
they've had to throw like 40 times you
know where they get real Up Tempo and
they get behind and I think Carr at
least has some semblance of
upside from mahomes's son shout out to
you uh for being patri Mahomes son
anyways mahomes's son says Deandre Swift
or Alvin CA so eagles found a ton of
success on Monday night against the
chiefs with those middle screens to
DeAndre Swift I think that was more game
plan in game specific than something
that they do regularly however the
chimra role has not been great leading
into their buy I mean he was losing a
ton of work was
chimra uh to Jamal Williams to Tamm hill
before the buy so yeah what do you think
about this one Leone Swift or Chima this
week
yeah I think I'll go chimra here just
because the improved pass down role I
mean if you were like a standard League
uh non PPR I might switch that to Swift
but anything else the pass down rooll
for Chima I think is a little bit more
important and yeah I I'll use that to go
with him over Swift yes huge NFC South
game this week between the Saints and
the Falcons going to go a long way
towards deciding who wins that Division
and makes the playoffs all
right for today show we are going to do
feast and fast so we have four players
here who we think are Feast AKA good
starts good plays this week and then we
have four guys who we think are fast AKA
bad plays this
week start with Z flowers I I'll go on Z
flowers first so what you get with Z
flowers is an improved Target projection
because Mark Andrews is out I think
Isaiah likely can play but he will not
command targets anywhere near the rate
that Mark Andrews commands targets and
so you get more targets to go around on
top of that Odell Beckham is dealing
with a shoulder injury I'm not sure how
successful or how much he'll be able to
play if he does play andot baitman was
added toward to the injury report with a
foot injury here today and you get the
worst pass defense in the entire NFL in
my opinion I mean the commanders might
be it but I'll say one of the worst pass
defenses in the NFL in the Chargers here
for Z flowers so for me this week Z
flowers Feast show me the
animation
yes great job by everyone at Bleacher
Report Leon I'll let you take the second
one yeah we've managed to contrive this
to get me to talk about Dalton concade
again which is you know truly something
here but kincade's Target share and you
know overall routes super consistent and
high since Dawson Knox has gone out now
they face a Philadelphia team that in
terms of pass rate against opponents are
throwing against them at the heaviest
amount in the league the average pass
rate against Philadelphia this season is
73% that's three points higher than any
other team in the league I think Buffalo
you know it looked like they were going
a little run heavier with the OC change
last week but I think that was matchup
driven against the Jets they're going to
throw a ton Dalton concade will benefit
from that game plan he is also a feast
I think that's the sound of a turkey
preparing to be slaughtered for
Thanksgiving yes everybody rejoice in
the Feast of Dalton King
Kate third let's go to chats actually B
Burgess 127 says David Montgomery or
Kiren Williams this week so kirn's back
and before Kirin went down and this has
been a while ago you know four or five
weeks ago he had an outrageous role did
Kiren will I mean one of the best roles
among any running back in the entire
NFL they've let Daryl Henderson go they
still have Royce Freeman on the other
side David Montgomery and Jamir Gibbs
are splitting stuff pretty much down the
middle but this team wants to get a ton
of running back touches and a ton of
running back touches around the goal
line as well my gut here is David
Montgomery over Kiren in his first game
back I know Leon you like to lean into
guys in their first game back though
what do you think about this
one yeah my gut is also David Montgomery
I just think the game plan is going to
be very runhe heavy for Detroit they're
going to put up a ton of points I will
say our initial projections for the week
have Kiren with slightly more points now
we're still working on those with that
game being over the weekend and the
uncertainty with him coming back um I
just feel like Montgomery is so safe I
wouldn't mess with it but the role for
Kiron gives him a bit more upside than
it probably feels making this a tougher
on V one than it than it appears on the
surface yeah I just think it's a good
spot for Montgomery you know home game
against the Packers short week you know
he's really liking a score touchdown I
think uh Max Parlin says Jordan Addison
or Nico Collins in the flex so Jordan
Addison has undoubtedly gotten worse
because of the quarterback situation I
like Josh dos there's no doubt he's
worse than Kirk Cousins Nico Collins
meanwhile I mean he is getting
incredible quarterback play right now
from CJ strad I think the concern on
Nico is just tanks better you know and I
didn't think I'd be saying that because
I like Nico but tank is is a baller and
it's hurting Nico a little bit I think
what do you think about this one Leone I
think it's really close I think that
Minnesota's in a pretty good spot
against Chicago a home in a dome Chicago
for a bad team has a really good run
defense so teams still throw against
them even though you know they they're
in a positive game script so that's good
for Addison all said and done though
going with the better quarterback play
going with Nico Collins in this matchup
Al get him in a in a dome spot against
Jacksonville last one here from chat
geek and isma says Jerome Ford Z flowers
or Isaiah pcho in the flex so I really
like Z flowers this week I talked about
that already P's role though man it's
pretty strong you know and they throw so
much around the goal line and they mix
in all these weird things they're very
throw heavy in general but given the
state of their team I actually think
they need to be more run heavy right now
they can certainly execute that I think
against the Raiders so as much as I like
Z I think I would go Pacho here what do
you think about this one Leon yeah I'd
rank it Pacho then flowers uh as the top
two in this Trio yeah all
right let's go back to the feast or fast
portion of the program I will take this
next one the next guy we're going to
talk about is is javante Williams so I
was scared by the usage that I saw from
javante Williams in their first game out
of the buy against the Vikings on Sunday
night I thought that that was going to
be a big chance for javante to continue
ascending in his usage instead what
happened was javante Williams got iced
in the past game Javon Williams only ran
four routes in that game perine and
mcclaflin combined for 19 routes I mean
that's not good and now you have a very
very difficult matchup on the ground for
Javonte Williams I know he's at home but
this Brown's defense has been absolutely
lights out so I will go with fast no
eating no eating 24-hour fast on javante
Williams I have done some fasts in my
life before uh didn't really feel too
much but might be good for you so fast
on javante Williams Leoni go ahead with
the fourth guy on the list here yeah
fourth guy on our list is Quenton
Johnston he is set season highs in route
share recently 89% routes in week nine
then 80% then 91% being forced to play a
lot however Adam not producing even
though he's forced to play a lot his
season yards per out run is
0.77 which is a really really bad number
and you know at some point you want to
be in on the rookie breakout but I I
think at this point we need to see it
first and I'm especially not going to
play it before I see it when going up
against a ball Baltimore defense that is
just insanely good allowing a league low
like 4.6 yards per attempt against it's
it's hard to even believe that uh so
with all that said qu and Johnson
another
[Music]
fast yeah I don't want to like write off
Quint Johnston for his career yet but he
is right now one of the worst full-time
wide receiv receivers in the NFL like
there's no metric or Stat you could find
that doesn't says anything but that
including tape Bros
all right let's jump into the fantasy
bundles presented by State Farm we
bundling your home and auto insurance is
just another way to save with the
personal price plan so for you guys who
are new here the bundle segment we take
teammates that we think will work well
together this week if anyone out there
plays DFS that's kind of our specialty
at establish the run if you're
interested in getting better at DFS
certainly come check it out but yes you
want to be stacking most likely in
tournaments in DFS tournaments in most
situations first bundle comes on
Thanksgiving it's hard to Fathom a much
better spot than the Cowboys pass game
is in this week this Washington
secondary and pass rush is just
absolutely inep and it was inep before
they traded away Chase young and montz
sweat I mean they had to bench their
first round quarterback pick they are an
absolute disaster and we saw Tommy
DeVito shred them last week now they
have to face Dak Prescott and this pass
game of Dallas which has been so throw
heavy lately so the first bundle is
going to be Dak and Brandon Cooks
obviously CD lamb is the alpha Target
here but I think Brandon Cooks has a
much more secure roll way ahead of
Michael Gallup and Jaylen Tolbert and
those guys so as the secondary option
here do prefer Brandon Cook stacked with
Dak Prescot Le only go ahead with the
second bundle yeah I'll go with more of
a value bundle here here A Sneak year
one with Will Levis and DeAndre Hopkins
for the Titans going up against Carolina
Panthers defense that's 28th in total
dvoa according to ftn and last week we
saw Hopkins get into the end zone
thankfully to save what was a low volume
day for him but it was a low volume day
for the whole offense they only ran 38
plays they had a high Rush rate in that
game previous three games we saw Levis
throw 39 39 and 29 times so the share of
the team's volume has been awesome for
DeAndre Hopkins lvis has sort of
unlocked his touchdown and downfield
ability that he still has so that is a
very good bundle this week going up
against
Carolina yes all right third bundle I'll
go to Leone's Hometown Josh Allen to
Steph Diggs it is difficult to run the
football on the Eagles I think that is
the strength of their defense where they
have been struggling is in the secondary
I mean speed they lacking big time in
the secondary and we've seen a lot of
receivers take advantage of that already
this year so I think you're going to see
a high volume game from Josh Allen here
in terms of attempts and I also think
you'll see a lot of success for Josh
Allen and Steph digs here Steph digs
coming off of a bit of a quiet game this
is a huge game for the bills I think
they'll be up for it and when they get
into these big games you can see 10 12
13 targets for Steph Diggs Allen to
Steph Diggs Alpha stack this week as
part of that game I like it a lot Le
only go ahead with our final bundle of
the
week yeah Lamar Jackson Tai likeley here
against this Chargers defense that has
really struggled against the pass in
particular we saw uh Jordan love and the
Packers who have struggled all year get
downfield and be successful against this
Chargers defense I think we'll see the
same thing out of Lamar and Isaiah
likely when Mark Andrews went out with
injury last week he ran 82% of the route
so I know the target targets weren't
great and he didn't put up the fantasy
points that you want to see but if he's
out there for that duration of time the
fantasy points will flow and I think
they're going to flow plenty this week
all right yeah Isa likely if anybody you
guys have followed preseason or Coastal
Carolina football you're likely very
familiar with Isaiah likeley I know
Coastal Carolina football has a big
following out there and Mr likeley all
right get back to the chat for a few
questions here busy Banks says Josh DS
or doson so we're going to get into a
bunch of these spots here this week Leon
where you have to make decisions early
Jan doson plays Thursday Josh DS has
been banged up with a knee injury he
doesn't play until Sunday my gut here is
just to take the healthy guy and I think
Josh DS will probably end up playing in
this game but last time we saw him he
aggravated that knee issue and had to
leave so I would prefer Josh DS he was
100% I think I probably just have to
take the healthier guy here as we sit on
Wednesday Thursday any thoughts on that
one Leone yeah that's where it's
important too to know if you have like a
backup on the bench I do think you know
our projection gap between Dotson and
Dons would be big enough that I'd want
to risk Downs if I had a backup even if
it was a little bit worse than doson and
take that gamble if you have absolutely
no backup to Downs and yeah I'm with you
take
doson all right next question comes from
Melissa Melissa says Calvin Ridley or
Terry McClaren this is another decision
that needs to be made by Thursday we did
get the Calvin Ridley breakout and I'm
sure if you guys have heard this if
you're on Twitter or fantasy football
Twitter which I highly recommend
everyone is but anyways if you're on
there you have probably seen this
narrative that people are pushing that Z
Jones presence unlocks Calvin Ridley in
other words Z Jones runs these Dusty
routes along the boundary allowing Cal
Ridley to run in the middle of the field
when Calley has played with Z Jones he's
been better I think that's like super
noisy doesn't make a ton of sense to me
I don't know if I buy that I do think
that Calvin Ridley though is just better
than Terry mclen so I might lean that
way anyways what do you think about this
one
Leone yeah uh Z Jones had such an impact
that Hayden wins of Underdog fantasy
tweeted that he was on the sideline for
Kelvin Ridley's touchdown um that that
was the impact that Z Jones had but like
you said I think Ridley's just a higher
ceiling play regardless of the Z Jones
stuff and you know I'm I'm gonna go that
route I know Washington could throw a
bajillion times in a negative game
script against Dallas but likely to be a
lot of really inefficient spread out at
past attempts oh my God B Kels this is a
humble brag when people send in
questions like this it's the ultimate
humble brag B Kels says Brandon iuk Mike
Evans or Steph Diggs buddy I would do
inhumane things to have two of these
guys on my bench on a given week these
are three of the best receivers in the
NFL I mean I'm not sitting Steph Diggs I
don't want to sit auk or Mike Evans
either but I'm not sitting Steph digs in
a huge game against the Eagles like
there there's just no way so it would be
Diggs for me Leon any thoughts
there n I'm with you digs the clear
starter Omar 760 asks Jay tler Barkley
Warren Gibbs who should I start 14 Man
league we got another humble brag here
another humble brag what is going on
another one um I'm assuming you can
start multiple of these players if not
it's a severe humble brag I know Jaylen
Warren's been like insane efficiency
wise but I chill on that one when you've
got you know guys like talor Barkley and
Gib right now probably would rank this
Gibbs then JT then Barkley but I know
JT's role was absolutely great um prior
to them heading into the buy last week
really took over the back field no more
split stuff with Zach Moss yeah for me
it's either JT or Gibbs is the best for
sure I might lean slightly towards JT
but it's an awesome get spot for Gibbs
also last question from MTM says Josh
dobs or Brock pie so one thing that you
get with Josh dobs I mean this dude
keeps running I mean just every week you
know 30 35 yards rushing I know he
scored a rushing touchdown last week
with pie you get the insane efficiency
that comes with playing and throwing to
CMC KD Debo auk certainly a tough one
here Leoni any thoughts perie or Mr
dobs yeah I do like dobs over some of
the Fringe starters but at this point I
don't really consider you know pery a
fringe starter he's averaging like over
10 yards per pass attempt it's absurd
their team totals in the high 20 again I
think you just have to keep playing pry
he's so safe because he's so efficient
um even if dobs is a little bit more
upside because of his running game I
think just the the safer more talented
offense is San Francisco and I'd play
pry all right let's get back to the
Thanksgiving theme segment feast or fast
fifth guy in that uh list is going to be
puka nikua now Cooper Cup last last week
suffered an ankle injury a low or mild
ankle sprain on the same ankle that he
had tight RPP surgery on over the
offseason he says he's fine he has a
chance to play Sunday even if he plays I
like this spot for pukaa a lot you play
at Arizona you know effectively Dome
conditions and you get a healthy Matthew
Stafford and a less than 100% Cooper Cup
against Arizona that is an ideal spot to
fire up puka nikua he is a
feast perfect we only go ahead with the
sixth one yeah Kell suvin asks thoughts
on Joe Mixon well Kell's in luck because
Joe Mixon does make our list this week
he had been performing a bit bit better
from a fantasy perspective the last few
weeks but I do think sometimes there's
dis misnomer when a quarterback is out
people are like oh the running back's
going to get more touches they're going
to lean on him we want high value
touches you know we want the touches by
the goal line we don't want touches
against stacked boxes between the 20s
and that's probably what you're going to
see with an unproven backup quarterback
here so Joe Mixon is a fast against a
good Pittsburgh
[Music]
defense yeah I mean Mixon has been
struggling for efficiency with Joe
burrow with Jake Browning it's going to
be against the Steelers it's going to be
major efficiency concerns and wa for
your opportunities to score touchdowns
when you have Jake Browning in there
instead of Joe burrow seventh one is
going to be Tyler Lockett this is the
Thursday game against the 49ers so Tyler
Lockett has been dealing with a
hamstring injury he's gonna play on
Thursday two concerns on Tyre locket one
Gino Smith has this throwing elbow
tricep issue which makes me
uncomfortable second San Francisco I
know they haven't like played up to
their ability yet San Francisco has the
ability the talent on defense to be
absolutely dominant and so I'm worried
that Seahawks could get whitewashed here
a little bit Tyler Lockett will be a
fast this
week last one
Leone all right Mike Evans we get him D
match up against the Colts I think this
could be an up and down game a little
bit with how uptempo the Colts play and
then Tampa B
um they try to run the ball but they
can't which means they have to throw the
ball and I've really been surprised all
season long that Evans has produced so
consistently I really thought it'd be
Chris Godwin with Baker Mayfield but
it's been Mike Evans week in and week
out don't really see any reason for that
to change this week Mike Evans the final
guy in our list is a
feast yeah Colt secondary really been
struggling and they play Fast certainly
a really good spot for Mike Evans all
right just a recap the list here our
Thanksgiving week feasts are Z flowers
donin Cade pukaa Mike Evans our fast
like me if you won't be eating at all
tomorrow Javonte Williams Quinton
Johnston Joe Mixon and Mr Tyler
Lockett all right got a little bit of
time here to take some questions from
chat Bobby salami says what are your
thoughts on Pierce and single ter this
week yes I actually have a lot of
thoughts here single Terry has played
well
enough to I think be the dominant force
in this backfield for the rest of the
season I think that the Texans think
even if sary isn't as taled as Damen
Pierce he runs the scheme better period
and for that reason I think we can
project 70 75% of the Touches for single
ter even when Damen Pierce comes back
which could be as soon as this week so
yes I think single carry this week Leon
if you want to take the next
question yeah and Thompson asks moster
or Gus Edwards and yeah that's a tough
one I mean both these backs are in
pretty good spots where I think they're
going to run the ball and their offenses
should be playing from ahead Edwards has
had this absolutely insane goal line
role so it's tempting to keep playing
him but I think mostard is the better
option I think there's a little bit more
upside in the past game I think there's
more big play Upside if Gus Edwards
keeps scoring two touchdowns a week it's
going to look foolish but when he scores
zero touchdowns he's really at the mercy
of maybe scoring like five fantasy
points especially with Kean Mitchell
playing more early down stuff yeah and
we'll see on Devon Anan status as well
but we also know Salan akmed went on IR
yesterday for the Dolphins too it's
getting a bit thinner there corrupted
Rivers says Amari
Cooper Brandon Cooks corland Sutton or
George Pickins so this is a tough one
the rumor out
of Pittsburgh is that with M can gone
one of the changes they will make is to
get George Pickins the football more
they have a very good matchup do the
Steelers here against the
Bengals I'm tempted to say Pickins I'm
curious Leone though if you think
there's
validity with this picking stuff because
if Mt Canon was still there it would not
be pickings for me I don't want to
overreact to this offensive coordinator
change so yeah any thoughts on Pickins
this week yeah I mean the total there so
low and the picking stuff I think is
less coordinator related more Deontay
Johnson related I think I'd actually
just play Brandon Cooks and just go all
in on this Dallas offense of that bunch
in such a good spot it's just hard you
know like Sutton and Amari are the
number one wi outs for their team and
you're thinking oh why would I play the
number two or number three option for
the Cowboys the Cowboys are going to
have volume and efficiency I think
that's the safe one is probably Cooks go
ahead with the next one Leon D nice
0930 love go Lawrence bench one gotta
love a good superflex to QB question
here I think you got to bench love I
mean uh there's some reasons to think he
could perform well here against Detroit
or at least have to throw the ball down
field I think the pass volume could be
up for him but man I mean gf's got a
team total that's like seven and a half
points higher you got to take that
touchdown upside Lawrence also team
total about a touchdown higher and just
a better quarterback overall so just go
with the talent and the insulated
offenses here with gof and Lawrence yeah
and the home road splits for gof are
just massive and he is home here against
a very burnable Packers defense cute boy
shout out to you says jayen Reid or DK
meaf you know I understand the matchup
considerations jayen Reed's also in the
injur report this week with a chest
issue I just can't sit DK mcaf for jayen
Reed I mean just like the talent Gap is
is so wide if Gino were to be ruled out
that would probably be okay going with
Reed but they've already said that Gino
is going to play here in this game so it
would be DK mchf for that one Leone do
you want to take the last one yeah last
one's difficult luano C asks cup aan or
Pitman fade one I I'm worried you might
have to end up fading two here depending
on the injury statuses for cup and hen
so we're keeping an eye out on that if
all three of these guys were healthy I'd
be fading Pitman um I'm worried they're
you know that's not the case but in a
perfect world where they're all healthy
I think cup and hn just have ceilings
that Pitman does not have I mean the
very first game and one of his very
first touches hn gets back he aggravates
you know and that that's scary to me you
know so yeah I think it it I think you
have to sit aan assuming that Cooper cup
is going to play we need to follow
practice reports
there all right that's going to do it
for this Thanksgiving edition of the
beach report fantasy football show
presented by State Farm we are running
Black Friday sale at establish the
run.com if anyone is interested there
head to the site and check it out but
more importantly thankful for all of you
being here listening to us talk about
football it's a privilege and we are
grateful that we able to do this for you
guys on a week- toe basis Happy
Thanksgiving to everyone out there for
everyone at bleach report everyone
establish the run for Michael Le I am
Adam good luck
everybody